- On this episode, I go really fast.
Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and welcome to episode 43
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Before we get into the episode,
I just want to wish my
amazing wife, Lizzy,
a happy 10th anniversary.
I'm thrilled to get to this milestone.
Tomorrow is my 39th birthday.
I will be going away with
Lizzy for the weekend,
so no show tomorrow.
So for the question of the day,
please just wish me a happy birthday.
Just excited.
Thank you guys for, uh.
This feels appropriate to say thank you
for watching the show.
I'm enjoying it.
I'm enjoying it so much that I have
a very important meeting in four minutes,
so we're gonna bang
out two quick questions
on a condensed, very
family celebration episode
of the #AskGaryVee show.
- [Voiceover] Mike asks,
"Shark Tank's Barbara Corcoran
doesn't invest in rich kids' businesses.
How do you feel about
entrepreneurs from privilege?"
- You know, Babs from the Shark Tank is
one of my favorite characters,
I like calling Barbara Babs,
that's just something
I've been doing for years.
Barbara Long, if you're watching,
that's where it started.
Wine industry chatter.
You know, look, I was very much, we all
have our prejudices.
Since I came from a zero place, I have
for a long time talked
about the rich kid syndrome.
Right now I talk about
the Ivy League, if I go
to an Ivy League school,
I should be a founder
because Zucks wears a
hoodie, I'm wearing a hoodie
so this is perfect timing.
For a long time, I really
pushed against that
and said they're not
hungry enough, they're not
pushed enough.
My kids are going to be
rich kids, and I think
what I've learned as I've gotten older,
39 tomorrow, and because of one or two
very special friends in my
life right now that grew up
very wealthy but are hungry and fiery
and making stuff happen,
I think it comes down to
anything like a business.
I talked about VaynerMedia, I
just had an amazing meeting
with somebody and they're
like, this place is so
caring and so good.
I thought it was going
to get worse when we got
to 400 versus 150, and I said look,
it stems from the top.
I actually give a crap, and I
think that trickles through.
That's the same thing on this.
I, when I meet rich kids,
and see their pitches,
spend 45 out of the 50
minutes asking them about
how they were raised, how
their parents played the game.
The reason I think my rich
kids are going to be OK
is because if they act too
rich kiddy, I'm going to
punch them directly in their mouth.
What I mean by that is, not like literally
because I know some of you will freak out.
Though I may go there, I'm a little weird
and Eastern European.
The truth is, I'm going to humble them.
I'm going to hurt their feelings,
I'm going to make them cry.
I'm going to tell them how soft they are.
I think that it comes
down to the parenting,
just like it comes down
to the CEO in a business.
Everything trickles from the top.
Just because you grew up
with a hundred million dollar
trust, doesn't mean that
you don't have the hunger
and just because you grew
up with thirty thousand
dollars in cash, maybe your
mom did everything for you
and took care of everything for you.
It's how you were raised.
What's the foundation?
It's the cement.
My dad, Wine Library was built
to be a 16 floor building
and everyone made fun of my dad
from an engineering standpoint.
He's an old school guy, he
just wants the foundation
to be strong and there's
too much steel and concrete
in the basement of Wine Library.
That's how I think about this question.
What's the foundation?
I'm not worried about the
optics, the interior decorating.
It's the foundation.
- [Voiceover] Zbra Studios
asks, "How long are you going
to make us wait for the Heart
To Brain To Wallet T-shirt
mentioned in episode 41?"
- Zbra, not too long.
(ding)
And the link's down below!
And that, my friends, is episode 43.
I know there's going to be comments,
I know there's going to be
a lot of happy anniversary,
happy birthday, I know
there's going to be like,
too fast, Gary, I like the longer shows.
I know!
But I don't have the time today.
We still pumped it out,
I'm gonna miss you,
I'm going to be back Tuesday.
We'll do it then.
Question of the day, there is none.
Just give me some love.
Oh, crap, wait, subscribe!
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks
in social, so subscribe!